here the goal is to kind of hopefully by
the end of this hour to have a little
better sense of these words and how they
fit together so I'm going to be talking
about things that Daniel talked about
just a little bit ago which is ground
states of local hamiltonians and
understanding them and yeah they
advertise the bait and switch was that
well it's not really being searched so
there's a one a little bit about 1d area
laws and also a recent algorithm for
finding ground states of 1d cyst caps
systems and I guess maybe it's worth
pointing out that at least for me the
notion of an AGS be an approximate
ground state protection it's sort of
emerging as kind of a really exciting
new tool for sort of looking at these
things so um alright so let's sort of
start somewhere so here the basic
difficulty of understanding many-body
physics is is just a matter of scale
you've got a bunch of particles together
and each particle sort of is modeled as
a d-dimensional space but if you want to
understand how the system works together
you end up having 24 n particles you
have two tensor those spaces together
right their interactions you have two
tensor them together and so what are you
talking about now you're talking about
due to the n-dimensional space and
exponential size space ok and so that's
a pretty large thing to be thinking
about and what do we end up wanting to
know is sort of the state of the system
in the state of the system ends up being
a vector in this exponentially large
thing and so we've kind of got this
double-edged sword right so the reason
computation quantum computation you know
the basis for it being powerful is the
fact that it works on an exponentially
large space but that also is makes
understanding anybody's physics really
difficult because we're working on an
exponentially large space and how do you
get ahold of that and in particular
right even giving a description of a
state right requires it next unless you
have some
clever way of doing it requires
exponential amount of information so
this seems this is sort of the basic
sort of difficulty that you're always
trying to navigate around sort of how do
you do any sort of physics or
computation on under these circumstances
so well how do you sort of explain a way
that maybe you can do something is well
you've got all these you know you've got
all states we said that's really really
big but maybe sort of you can find a
little corner with sort of the relevant
a set of relevant states for what you're
looking for maybe you can find a corner
where you can really sort of do some
analysis and what kind of analysis would
you want to do what kind of
understanding what you want what kinds
of questions would you want to ask what
you want to ask well in these sort of
physically relevant states of some sort
do they have any special structure and
can i exploit that structure in some way
so first even just understanding that it
has a special structure sort of
constitutes understanding but so for one
thing can we describe them in some
reasonable way and can we subscribe them
in a reasonable way in a way so that we
can compute with so again with this all
these are all questions around sort of
taking something that's inherently
exponential in nature and sort of
reducing it down to something that's so
right so what are the states that we're
talking about where the states we're
going to talk about our ground state
with local hamiltonians and I've sort of
benefited from the fact that the mesh
has sort of brought up this and daniel
has brought up this stuff so this is
your third time through if you've been
here for two days so hopefully this will
sound sort of strangely and lastingly
familiar okay so what what what is this
sort of set up and we're going to be
talking about in this case we're going
to sort of picture of particles on a
lattice a two-dimensional lattice and so
they're sitting there and what do we
have to sort of form a local Hamiltonian
we have the notion of a local term and
so what does a local term mean well it's
a operator linear operator self adjoint
and it's uh these two particles
constitute a small tensor product of
these two spaces as
small space okay and we're going to
think of H I as an operator that acts on
that small space in some interesting way
and then acts on the rest of the space
as a tensor product for the identity so
this is a local term so it's locally its
acting does something interesting there
and cancered with the identity
everywhere else that's the notion of a
local term and as sort of was discussed
by Daniel so so in in general people
well or maybe computer scientists as we
sort of discovered when they say local
they don't necessarily mean
geometrically local they just mean a
small number of terms in their
interaction but we're really going to
focus on geometrically local so there's
going to be a notion of some geometry
the particles and now local means you
only act on a few of them and they're
near each other and I it turns out that
this is just as good acting on two of
them is just as good because you can if
you have something that's acting on
let's say no more than K you can kind of
break up your space into bigger trucks
group group instead of one particle sort
of group a bunch of particles together
call that a single mega system and
realize these local terms in this way so
this is this is the setup and what is a
local so this is a local term of a
Hamiltonian what's a Hamilton okle
Hamiltonian itself it's a operator
itself and it's a sum of local operators
right so here we've got an edge for each
each each each one of these edges
represents an interaction local term
that's acting non-trivial early on let's
say these two particles and tribulus
we've some this thing up we get an
operator on the whole space and what are
we interested in this case we're
interested in what's called the ground
state which is the lowest the smallest
eigen vector of age sort of we've been
some discussion about understanding this
is somehow understanding something about
physical models at low temperature sort
of getting a sense of what this ground
state looks like and there's some
okay this was sort of a relevant
quantity that keeps coming up and so
let's just make sure we say it at the
outset is the gap and what is the gap
it's so this local Hamiltonian let's
just imagine ordering its eigenvectors
with multiplicity sorry its eigenvalues
I always do this its eigenvalues with
most Felicity from smallest to biggest
so the smallest one is the ground state
and the gap refers to the distance
between the smallest and the next fall
so in particular if we talk about
something that has a gap we aren't
talking about a system at least for the
purposes of this talk we're not talking
about system where there's the lowest
there multiple I ghen vectors for the
smallest eigenvalue all right so we're
sort of picturing a unique smallest
eigenvalue vector and then a gap and by
a gap we talk about that distance and
usually when we say gap Hamiltonians we
mean that distance is a constant I guess
I should have said somewhere along the
lines which I didn't write down anywhere
that these local terms these H I are
thought to be of operator norm a
constant order one and in fact you can
think about them if you just want it to
do it and it's not particularly damaging
to think about H is just projections
right so you can think about each of
these little interactions is picking out
some subspace of this the tensor product
of these two spaces is being and
penalizing things that aren't living in
that subspace in the you okay so then
when we the interesting sort of in terms
of gap this is the distance between the
lowest and the and the second lowest and
just to get a sense of scale right the
norm of this of age in this particular
case is on the order of N squared each
of the turn there n squared terms each
of them over order 1 you expect the norm
to be around our order N squared and we
end up talking a lot about something
that has constant gaps so it's constant
relative to this n square ok so this is
just what I said that we're going to
focus on unique ground state with
constant fat and that the physical
just the physical relevance of this
inspiration so okay so okay so so
quantum Hamiltonian complexity which
this is a whole semester on right has
those words quantum Hamiltonian
complexity so let me just talk about
this the strong length which mesh also
talked about between ground states of
local hamiltonians which is a physically
motivated question and and constraint
satisfaction problems which existed
separately as the were a complexity
there so here's you know three saddest
or sat sat sat is something that people
with sort of the standard-bearer for
constraint satisfaction problem but I'm
just going to sort of just to give you a
sense I'm just going to give you a
different one and so in this case I'm
going to talk about three color ability
because it gives you the it'll be good
for the geometry of the connection so
here's the question I give you a map
right here's a map and I say look i
wanna i want you to sort of make a nice
presentation of this map i want you to
color this map unfortunately colors cost
something so we only have three colors
that we can use and I want this map to
really shine in the presentation that
whatever we're giving so I'm going to
ask you to color this map in three
different colors in such a way that two
neighboring countries aren't the same
color so that they don't blend one to
the other and so this is this is the
question of can I color this map with
three colors okay so one way to sort of
attack this problem or analyze this
problem is they okay well I'm going to
put a vertex right for each region and
I'm going to assign so that vertex will
be assigned a color and what is it that
I want to do is I want to make sure that
neighboring countries don't have the
same color so I'm going to throw in an
edge for every neighboring countries I
get a picture like that and that edge is
going to say hey let's just make sure
that if you are on two ends of an edge
they're not labeled by the same color so
i can now remove the actual map or two
but now i have a graph so what do I have
a graph I have a graph where each of the
nodes
graph represents the possible colors and
the edges represent what's called a
constraint and in this particular case
the constraint insists that what you
label one edge with one end of one edge
is different from what you label the
other age and then you're interested in
finding an assignment of all the blue
dots right such that all the constraints
are satisfied and more generally you
might ask the question of what's the
minimal number of constraints that I
have to you know maybe there isn't an
assignment for all but what's the
minimal amount that I have to violate so
that's the classical that's that's a
three-color ability and I think if you
ask three-color ability for I think for
planar graphs that are 4-valent at least
degree bound even degree bounded by for
this becomes a an MP problem and so you
know in complexity theory you're solving
classifying and understanding these
things and more general constraint
satisfaction problems is sort of that's
where it's at so all right so this
already I mean I sort of set this up so
that this has some similar flavor to to
local hamiltonians but the flavors it's
not only a flavor it's really sort of a
precise generalization so let's sort of
go through that right so so the heart of
the matter is that that local
hamiltonians are going to turn out to be
a non community of generalization of
constraint satisfaction problems so
let's sort of just explicitly make that
clear right so now let's go back to our
local Hamiltonian sort of picture of
really the particles aligned on a lot to
degrade right and so let's so each
particle right so the particle in the in
the three color roll problem where the
colorable problem was sort of in what
did the particle the information that it
contained is a possible different number
of colors and in the local Hamiltonian
setting it's the dimension of a single
particle or if we had clustered them
together it's the local dimension of the
local space at the local term was in
both cases was a local constraint and
here is he
is where the generalization occurs if
you think if you start to think about
constraint satisfaction problems in this
way which you realize about what this
constraint looks like is that it's
diagonal and if you're really talking
about constraints of violating and
constrain and nonviolent in constraint
it's just picking out it's on the
diagonal and it puts a one for any for
any labeling of the of these guys for
which the constraint is violated and it
puts a zero along the diagonal
corresponding to for anyone's that's
that it's satisfied and so it's diagonal
I by diagonal I mean in the standard
basis of the natural basis of this
problem this is diagonal whereas for the
local Hamiltonian terms these can be
arbitrary and that's an arbitrary but I
already said you could serve havoc you
think about it pretty simply as just a
some projection but not a projection
that's diagonal necessarily okay so this
is the sense in which this is a non
community of generalization because
these constraints they all commute 12
notes right whereas these constraints do
okay and so now let's just sort of
continue just the the correspondence
right if I set this up in this way right
the assignment that it violates the
fewest constraints corresponds exactly
to the ground state or the lowest
eigenvalue to the assignment that set
violates the fewest constraint will be
the lowest eigen a eigen vector of this
of this problem and the lowest
eigenvalue will be the least number of
constraints violated and whereas in this
case the lowest eigenvalue will be the
minimal energy the energy that the
ground state has
is that clear when he dies the local
turned off because if that they're much
stronger
than constraint enforcing so it's a sick
ass you what is it what is not clear or
what is clear what do you this happening
that the constraint satisfying solution
is the lowest i united state when you
have the non commuting the local right
so--okay so um I think this might be
just a semantical thing but what I'm
what I'm saying is you you know once you
have this correspondence the first two
correspondences you can think of this
problem as an example of this problem
where the concise right and then as such
when we start talking about ground
States what does that mean in the
language of this it's the assignment
that violation of fewest constraints
which was exactly the thing of interest
that we had in the classical setting or
another thing of interest was the least
number of constraints violated maybe you
don't want to know the assignment you
just want to know whether it's doable or
not right and the least number of
constraints corresponds to the lowest
eigenvalue so that that these things
that we were interested in for physical
reasons turn out to be the exact same
things that we would be interested in
from a computer so when you say
particular vendor community so there is
a difference if they are no I sure yeah
so let's dear yeah so let's and that
will actually come up later so let me
say that one difference between this and
this is that these guys commute these
guys don't have to commute there's but
there are certainly examples that aren't
diagonal where they all commute they're
just going to different there in two
different places so it's not the case
that if I take this the local
Hamiltonian problem and I ask for all
the constraints to commute that they
that means that there is a there is a
example it's it's it's that they have to
be diagonal in the standard basis which
as a consequence means they commute but
it's just an example I think interesting
point is that
sticky the two bottom man approaches are
equivalent and if you know that the just
that the number of if you can solve the
how whether there exists something that
satisfy all its solution can help you
find solution using some putting on a
reduction for most interesting problems
and but it should be noted that that we
don't know the same thing for in the
quantum case and somehow this is usually
not spelled out you see what do you see
my arm yeah so what it so if you know to
find that the lowest i can value that i
don't know if any way to help you to
find the ground state suppose it gives
you an oracle that helps you find that
those eigen value can you construct this
in the crown by state what do you think
classic meal a secure you can know that
if you can find that if you know that
there is an assignment you can know
tweak your problem it's in certain ways
and then it will help you to find a 10
the decision to search reduction in
there may be some of those irani horses
i don't know i just tried I never
succeeded I don't know I was clear to me
though I didn't but somebody asks
something if it was it's worth yeah
great own i guess i should say 44 um i
guess i should say in general for four
people can there was a sort of a year
ago there was a kind of a pre-conference
for this sort of thing and one of the
consequences of that was some talks
didn't get past about their second slide
because everybody asked questions and
there was a lot of things like that and
and I it's definitely my opinion i think
was shared by a bunch of other people
that that was one of the best
conferences we had ever been to and so
in that spirit please i challenge you to
prevent me from getting
my son okay so all right so we've set up
this this this correspondence so now
we're going to sort we sort of took this
little detour to sort of go through the
classical world to understand this
correspondence let's go back to this
question of understanding the ground
states right and so what now we were
sort of solid with the idea what a
ground state is and so I'm just going to
remind you of these questions that sort
of sitting out do they have special
structure to the structure allow for
short meaningful descriptions and can
you work with these description I mean
there is you know a priori there is a
short meaningful description i give you
the hamiltonian that's a meaningful
description i say you know it's the
ground state of this thing but you know
right so that's a short meaning full
description but doesn't allow you to
work with it okay and so the spoiler to
the thing is that for gapped one bae
systems caffeinating confident gap the
answer is yes and for higher dimensions
the answers don't know specify we bike
konsa can I think it's been discussed
early okay so constant so we let's
assume all the local terms are of order
operator norm one so the actual
Hamiltonian could be if it was on a 2d
grid could have a norm up to like let's
say N squared but the constant gap we're
talking about is a fixed constant
independent of n and by gap we mean the
difference between the distance between
the lowest Integra love it
and you know if you were to ask me what
an ambitious but exciting goal for for
the semester would be would be to make
some progress on this higher dimensional
stuff there's reason to think that now
is the time to do that which hopefully
by the end of the talk you'll have some
time okay so let's try to understand so
this is so i should say that you know i
come from a math background so my i'm
excited about this particular thing for
a lot of reasons but one is because i
want to understand physics intuition and
to some extent CS intuition about some a
lot of these things so i'm going to give
you a particular point of view of this
this journey of understanding ground
states and i sort of with the caveat the
deceased this is from a particular
perspective okay this may have really
been on suggest it for the 1d gap system
can you verify that it is gap no i mean
we don't know how did
you know has
mentioned to the clarifying the guardian
futoshi jr. may be the case that based
on this algorithm you might be able to
actually make progress on actually
verifying gaps with but they are motile
there are other pieces we've talked
about which which are missing too
liberally it's an interesting question
it and know whether I should echo okay
so this is something my dad in math sort
of would tell me every once in a while
chuckling over breakfast or lunch or
something in theory there is no
difference between theory and practice
but in practice there is right and so as
I was sort of trying to sort of map out
how what I was going to say about sort
of the story I kind of felt like one of
the themes going through it was that
theory and practice sort of this sort of
this evolution where theory and practice
diverge and they come together and they
diverge again and I come together so in
preparation I sort of tried to look up
who this quote is due to and it seems a
little controversial in terms of
different people have said to it but one
person who is definitely credited with
having said this who I was not expecting
was yogi berra who I don't know how many
of you who know who he is but he's and
was a wonderful catcher baseball player
and manager of the Yankees and he has
the reputation of saying lots of things
that you kind of nod your head and say
even though it sounds ridiculous it's
kind of right so he's he's the one who
said it it ain't over till it's over or
he's also the one who said that
restaurants so popular nobody goes there
anymore so he's kind of anyway so anyway
so he's one of these so anyway
perhaps not particularly relevant but
but so again so the question is how do
you know how do you do physics with this
exponentially sized space and so here's
what happens in too deep white
introduced this idea of a density matrix
renormalization group as a algorithm for
finding ground states of 1d systems and
it sort of pivoted on its on the the
assumption that ground states should
have a matrix product state
representation and I'm not going to
spend any time saying what that is but
but I can sort of promote it as a reason
to come to the tensor network boot camp
thing on Saturday anyway it's it's a
it's a matrix product state
representation is sort of basically what
we're kind of looking for which is sort
of a representation of a set of states
for which you can do you can actually do
calculations and just sort of you said
well you know this was a model and let's
see what we can do with it and the
result was that it had remarkable
success in one dimension sort of really
it was you know and really is still
considered to be the kind of both
standard for for what you can do
computationally approximation or is it
precise like can you express it exactly
as I say
so so at the drones day yeah so you're
asking should we flash forward to the
present is that is that so so what's
known is that there's very good
arbitrarily good approximations with
with matrix product states with with I
guess polynomial size banda mention I'm
here that's meaningful but at the time
it would just sort of let's try to see
what how good a how good a state we can
find of this form it minimizes the
energy and it turned out for I don't
know the history all that well to say
how how is determined that things were
doing really well but but in terms of
precisely to say hey this is actually
doing well big but it has been very
successful ya'll said it historically
like the matrix ponga states came first
in the AK LT model where we made the
model so that the beta proton states
part exact solutions or with small
invention so there are particular waters
where we know but in general when we
solve these problems but approximately
believe you can always approximately and
I guess I should say that if you allow
the bond dimension to grow you get
everything but that's then you're just
dealing with that exponential amount of
wizard yeah so can he always would be
applying to duty can we can this
algorithm be applied um in theory yeah
yeah and it has been tried in various
ways would I had people not really
particularly successful it's not not
that it's been trying it's been used all
the time like really you take a 2d
lattice and then you pretend it's a
chain like this that's what we do all
the time so the other itself is
formulated only for what the élevage has
42 needed one video
so you have to view the 27 1 be a bit
more interaction like so I suppose
though they are they are well known
cases say doesn't work so that becomes
kind of benchmark for people to test
their to do isn't it just it's so it's
slow and you need my large because the
corner imagine that you have a 2d system
and you make a chain out of this so this
guy interacts with the right from the
next level so to carry that information
yet you don't have it all the way around
so then you need to realize dimension of
the matrices so large meaning non
polynomial in practice means like
thousands millions whatever but this is
like a theoretical example where you can
show that there is no matrix like for to
be there is no matrix product state for
this particular setting door for this
particular area Tony so can so this one
ever exhibit Hamiltonian into the for
which there is no matrix product state
that approximates the ground state I
think you can just tensor up so you know
so one of the okay so maybe more of this
should be done offline but but I think
one thing to say is that if you model it
by a matrix product state that's sort of
leaving around the bond of you know the
the amount of entanglement between two
let's say layers right is sort of has
been shrunk to just this one bond and so
that bond has to get very very large
because you can create states that have
lots of entanglement so you need to
approximate you need to know that that
bonds was fun
easily
but then what you are saying is that the
problem is actually is known not to be
solvable but using a chain the hope is
that that for the mall system that
you're working on the entanglements very
very is small enough so that this is
capturing the special assessment so the
whole losses or specialist systems all
these algorithms are run on particular
examples
jeans so probably be here about it
independent
okay okay so so I think at the time this
was sort of thought to be really
something amazing and there's some real
sense in which it was working without
people necessarily there was sort of
heuristics involved it was working it
wasn't over time it was deemed that
sometimes it didn't work and more
heuristics were put in place and but
there was sort of some sense that there
was a missing there was sort of a lot of
intuition but there was a missing sort
of grounded basis and a zoo mesh likes
to say for you can do it in practice but
can you do it in theory right so that's
sort of right now I would serve say that
right at that particular moment there's
sort of a dissonance between sort of
what was a very surprising practical
result for which theory had no great
explanation so we sort of fast forward
to 297 when um to thi have sort of
introduced the notion of qma the quantum
analogue Yuma and P ensure that finding
ground states of general quantum systems
can remain complete which is sort of
discussed a little bit before and so
that put some sort of theoretical
framework on this idea that these guys
are least in general not for 1d systems
but in general this is a hard problem
and we shouldn't expect to have an
algorithm that works okay and slowly
slowly people refine this argument right
and so you know 50 60 these were general
Hamilton o'cl Hamilton is not
necessarily geometric as we're talking
about but in 05 and 06 this became true
of a 2d system to DQ ma
and so at that point there was sort of
this sense in which well maybe we have
some sense of what's going on so Trudy
systems are hard that makes sense right
1d systems classically 1d system
constraint satisfaction problems those
are solvable those are easy and so maybe
that's what's going on right the quantum
world did 1d systems are our we've got
an algorithm that seems to work sort of
so maybe it's just that they're you know
in 1d that's the that's the the
geometric constraint of 1d is enough to
make these things ease and so we were
all so everybody was happy until there's
a result that said actually 1b systems
are also hard and so solving wendy
systems are also qar and so that's sort
of again brings in this distance right
you've got this algorithm that does it
on the other hand it's supposed to be
hard and the algorithm does it in
practice it on particular examples with
its Vista and I guess as has been
referred in sort of reference it sort of
maybe both in hindsight and maybe even
at the time but probably not that the
notion of a gap here for the hard the
hardness results have gaps that are
smaller than constant and so in
hindsight we can sort of say okay well
these are not the same problems and
especially in hindsight when we know
that once with constant gap are solvable
we can sort of say okay that was that
was the things with did the time that
all right so simultaneous to this we
haven't sort of brought it up but the
biggest word on that original screen was
area law and so here here's the time to
introduce that so an area law what so
what is it it's sort of a it's kind of
an idea of the what the structure of
ground state should look like in some
complexity formulation and again I'm not
from the physics background but it as
far as i understand it sort of key it's
or there's a holographic principle in
cosmology which says something about
black holes and that the energy is sort
of sort of displayed on the boundaries
were focused sort of lives on the
boundary and and that translated to
to to sort of this general sort of idea
which is that the complexity of the
system of the quantum system should
depend only on the size of the boundary
and by the size of the boundary the idea
was that there you've got these local
interactions and how you know should
depend on how many local interactions
cross the boundary in terms of
understanding the complexity of the
system between the inside and the
outside I am being deliberately vague
about what i mean by complexity reserve
because for now you can just think of it
vaguely like that and so this this
notion called an area law which is not
necessarily a law in the sense that nope
it was an idea and concept that people
believe might be true still do but
nothing had been proven was then
formalized in some in some way where
complexity was formalized in terms of
entanglement entropy which let's see
we'll probably hear about this afternoon
yeah we should learn here it's this
afternoon right yeah the room yeah so so
I'm not going to spend any time on in
Kenya afternoon but it's a sort of
measure of the amount of complexity of
the system across this boundary um and
and just that sort of those ideas kind
of fueled uh sort of really did end up
applying to DM RG the sort of the ideas
of thinking about it this way led to
better so better heuristics some speed
up some simplifications a better
understanding of what was going on ok so
despite this fact we're still at the
stage where they're the area law is just
a projection so there's no proofs of
anything that we could serve if
continuing with the theory and practice
thing there's there's no sirve there
wasn't there wasn't quite resonance
because theoretically we didn't have any
proofs for the area law and that changed
in 2007 when Matt Hastings proved a one
day Arielle right so let's just make
sure we understand what it means what
we're saying in
terms of in my big way that I'm saying
it which is that you've got a 1d system
right and the amount of entanglement for
those of you who know what that means
that's fine for those of you not it's
sort of amount of crosstalking that
occurs across the foundry in terms of
describing the state should be just
dependent on the amount of interactions
across this boundary and so in this case
despite the fact that there are maybe n
particles and those particles or you
know the number of particles in each
side grow the amount of entanglement
should be should be bounded by a
constant right which sort of translates
sort of to sort of the idea that even
even though you can have a lot of
particles way out here and way out here
really sort of all the talking is sort
of local that's the kind of general
picture okay and I hey think this
further than that he not only did show
that a stylish scenario but he also
showed that it did these states did have
good approximations that look like MPs s
interest roddick states right so finally
we've got some sort of thing okay this
idea that they should look like this or
they could look like this let's model
will look like this well thats verified
that they could all right and so that
presented a picture right and so here
was the picture right so you've got one
bee suit solutions and you have a
dividing line between those for which
DMRC would work we can sort of maybe say
loosely say they're easy which is a
misnomer but they're sort of we can get
a handle on them and that dividing line
should be where the area law holds where
they are a law holds we should maybe
these ideas should baby work and where
they were they don't bank so that was
that was great sort of gave us such a
sense of you know all is well again
right until these guys came up with an
example of some of a ground state that
satisfied Mariola but for which finding
it was np-hard it's okay provides an
example for which the area law holds but
for which tmrg unless it was the energy
was not going to work
okay so so there are a lot of things are
going to be hard to develop those type
of wounds so oh so this is saying right
Saudi MRG is sort of an algorithm I
without any proofs that it works and it
was working on a lot of things I once
the 1d area law came along and said hey
look you know the assumptions you make
on do you enjoy about the way things
look is right so it seems very
reasonable that you could find them then
being here this it seems to be working
so the picture is that in 1d solutions
we have a dichotomy between where the
area law holds and where it doesn't and
for those problems where it holds the
MRG should work however then came the
result that said hey here's an example
of a problem where the area law holds
but finding the solution is hard so that
sort of gives us you know that that says
this is sort of an artificial dividing
line because here's something that lies
over here for which we were pretty sure
you're not gonna be able to do this so
it's a one-day system undie system and
satisfies the area load not because they
were after the deadly it sort of it was
built up it was a constructive exact
suit that's so good Hastings prove that
you're in place I think stronger than
the aryl also learned the MP harness it
was all avail being a ye wait good
actually so for example one in her
friend is
is the inner workings prove something I
don't think so do you think so no and I
think web so your power on so it is
Ariel all your cover into some 'cimmanon
of how many degrees yeah as a proxy for
it you can if it's helpful as a proxy
for it you can sort of say that this
picture of a matrix product state that
sort of has a polynomial side fog
dimension this may be worse rather than
better than whatever you were thinking
of it but you can sort of say that
there's a good approximation using a
matrix product state with polynomial
bond dimension but maybe that's not
helpful so ask your question one for
example I think there are many ways that
they will can be satisfied so for
somebody of the entanglement is
decreasing double exponentially that
satisfied that would make system satisfy
here at all right so if it worsens you
can actually implies is decreasing super
fast maybe that would rule out that the
harness yourself
so so printing and heavier gold by
itself it was not sufficient to get the
small matrix products did you know for
that these things had to do it in the
proper notion of here to get get it not
just using entanglement entropy but some
other foreign country but this example
you know what what it was saying was not
only does it doesn't satisfy the area
law but in fact you have a small make
its products and then you just can't
find it in addition I guess that's
theory of the kospi killin it won't look
into hastings because maybe they're
asian applications it may not be the new
apartment we know if we're in some
mathematical sense it does because now
we know that there is you know it is
true
and intuition there's someone better too
so my understanding is yes in many ways
that there's someone in the corner there
who's probably Daniel D is there so for
is there a reason that constant gap
systems have a physical more likely
physical the quantum holds the stove us
gaap right it's very physical there's
one exam that's one example but is there
a reason is there a reason to think bye
so there are the assistance you don't
need to be constantly get that you could
have a gap that decays exponentially to
a concert with system center then the
constant gap is a stronger statement it
also what we need more about it I calls
that dance move yeah oh yeah it means
they're at least at least this much and
pity colony back with the air of a
polynomial to just say there's not yet
yeah so it would have been enlightening
to so there are 44 notions so gap exists
Ariel holds the range of interaction is
small and there exists a matrix product
state our certain implications hold so
in between these four right and that's
what you were talking about that in
between these four like for instance now
in 1d we know that from gap we know that
area holds now I don't know for instance
if from area hope we can use long-range
that the interaction is on
I mean that the long range or the other
layer just purely area law does not
imply that the interactions aren't long
range but major product England Monday
and then finally the product state
assumption which one of these other
three so there are these four things and
just I mean it just would be very fun to
see what the implications are okay so
also here it seems like you would want
to produce an example that was harder
than NP in order to knocks out that
diagram right the first statement says
there in envy you could be any harder
than envy of course but but np-hard
shouldn't have an algorithm that solves
them right that's true so density matrix
normalization group is a polynomial time
algorithm and then back tomorrow but
tonight I'm not sure I can do this on
the fly in terms of and get it accurate
then we also want to offer anything up I
mean I can say that from my point of
view when I think area law I really am
thinking of it as approximate able by a
matrix product state regardless of
whether that's in fact the exact
statement that area law as formulated in
terms of entanglement entropy site which
which I think it's not it's not
equivalent but sort of way well your
conscience intensity is low so you would
certainly have you know one bit of
entropy can be perfect correlation
one bit so you know and from if you just
an aerial law does that mean that
correlations are small so i think it's
um the implication goes in the other
direction or maybe lower the age i know
it is known that if the correlations are
exponentially decaying it at least in 1d
that applies an area log in one do you
understand that 2d we just don't know
yet all right i should i should move on
cuz okay so i think you've met my
challenge quite well quite well i
shouldn't really be pushing you to do
anything different um okay so so um
essentially perhaps this is revisionist
history but but at least the way I see
it is this is sort of at the bad about
the time that I started thinking about
this problem and mesh maybe have a
different account but but the account
that i remember is something along the
lines of i think actually maybe even it
was you tie who sort of sort of took a
look at hastings result and said this is
really this is where we should be
spending some time and um it's a it's a
it's a five page paper right so i don't
know if other people encounter this but
you know i think if i paved paper i can
handle this right so i went at this
thing for a long time and with really
minimal success in terms of gaining any
kind of intuition i could sort of follow
the steps but really nothing and would
put it down and would start to think
about it say well maybe I can just
proved it some other way and eventually
would sort of get discouraged and come
back to this idea of like it's only five
pages come on how hard could this be so
I went back and forth of this and sort
of eventually sort of without
necessarily thinking of this there's
this is you know if there's a problem
you can't solve dude there's an easier
problem problem that you also can't find
solve and you should find it and polio
is also quoted with with changing that
can't to can so it's not a clear where
you go but you sort of keep going down
and hopefully eventually find something
and then kind of go back up so all right
so that's my motivation for saying hey
let's take a look at frustrating
frustration free computing case okay so
what am I going to ask for now I'm going
to ask for the Hamiltonians I so
frustration-free means that that the
ground state actually is going to
satisfy each of the each of the pieces
separately so another way to say that is
that the actual lowest eigenvector is
going to be 0 and I'm going to assume
that the sorry I'm going to assume that
the local terms are projections and not
only that i'm going to assume that they
commute and as was pointed out sort of
earlier that sort of reminiscent of the
classical case but i'm not going to
assume they're diagonal i'm just going
to assume that they can be it's a little
more all right and so here's it so this
is so I'm explaining this and you should
probably ask questions about this
because this gives intuition for for
what's coming next okay so if you have a
bunch of projections that commute and
you're adding them up and you want the
the one with lowest energy start by
taking each projection and and flipping
it take 1 minus it all right so now that
gives highest energy to it sort of
highest energy or it projects into the
space that includes the ground space the
range is it includes the ground face and
now you can multiply all these guys
together take each of those 1 minus
those projections and multiply them all
together and normally you just get some
strange operator and the end the end the
order that you multiply it would matter
but in the community case the order
doesn't matter so you can multiply them
all together and if you think about it a
little bit take a bunch of protections
that you know commute and you multiply
them all together you end up with a
projection and what do you end up with
the production of you end up with the
projection onto the only thing that
satisfies all the individual pieces
which is the ground state so just by
taking all these projections and
multiplying them together you get a
projection onto the ground state which
means that I can start with any state
apply this projection and all I have it
I have the ground state or I have a
scale multiple at the ground as long as
the thing I started with was north ave
and so that's what you can do in the
frustrating free commuting case and what
do you end up with you end up with
exactly a projection onto the ground
state and because the projection just
looks like a product of things and those
things are all little local pieces the
complexity of it is pretty small i still
haven't said what complexity is but it's
pretty swamp and so and that's in fact
if once you do that is you can prove an
aerial offer this particular case now of
course in general that's not the case
they're not going to commute stuff like
that but it gives you an idea of what
you want and here's what you want right
how do you generalize this idea in the
notion of approximate ground state
projection and this is the thing that
sort of drives all the results that come
up and so what do I want out of
approximate ground States projection
well the first thing that I want is that
it almost projects onto the ground space
and so what is a ground state so what
does that mean it means that it keeps
the ground state fixed while smashing
the perpendicular space thank you
whatever norm you have in the
perpendicular space reduce it a
projection would reduce it all 20 here
we're just going to reduce it and the
other thing you want because we had it
up there is it's not too complex not too
complex because we need that to sort of
eventually say that the ground speak
state is not too fast and with this idea
and a lot of work right okay and you can
construct it different approximate
ground state projections with different
properties and trade-offs of complexity
and in different things but complexity
and the amount that it shrinks things
down and locality but 22 results came
out of this the first was the different
proof of the 1d area law that
exponentially improved the parameters so
it was sort of a fundamentally different
proof improve the parameters from
Hastings result exponentially so much so
that if you're trying to sort of now
generalize that to two dimensions you're
right at the cusp of saying something
interesting for two dimensions so any
improvement on these
constancy will get you a sub volume wall
and it also provided a much better
matrix product state which perimeters
the parameters of the amount of
entanglement so there's a constant
associated to the entanglement that
depends on a bunch of things including
the gap and the dimension of the
individual particle space and it's such
that that constant if you tried to scale
that up to a 2d thing so it ends up
being just at the at the plaintiff if
you do sort of what would be the natural
thing to try to scale this up to the
two-dimensional thing by doing this food
is that okay and it also said that the
matrix product state the bond dimension
on it is actually sublinear which was
small enough so that you actually got a
sub exponential time algorithm for
finding solutions so that was sort of
the first sign for which maybe you could
actually actually that in fact gap
systems might have an alga provable
algorithm that was you know we already
had to stop a exponential time think so
maybe there's mine sure enough after all
some other work it resulted in a pond or
the plan for finding solutions to gapped
1d systems and so this sort of
represents kind of a closure of that
sort of picture because D MRG this is
not this algorithm is not what D MRG
does but surely there is an edge between
them but it also says hey look this this
this whole program is doable these types
of problems for gas systems this can be
done and so it sort of puts things in a
little bit of my language and here's the
picture that you had ended up having
which is that the dichotomy is not
between area laws but the dichotomy is
where a GSP's exists because they are
the driving force for both simulation
results and area laws and there are
others for which area laws hold but for
which you can't get at them in terms of
so
okay so let me say sort of just a little
more about the consequences of these
things right so I already said the
exponential improvement of the constants
which among other things implies that
you're just at the cusp of saying
something for 2d you've got an algorithm
for 1d gives you a definitely sense of
what's going on and it gives you some
tools for attacking the 2d and I'm
feeling like I'm running low on time but
I want to well I want to give some sense
of something about how these guys work
so let me let me show you how the AGS be
sort of the idea of the age is P in
terms of how it sort of helps you with
an area law and so for the area law
here's here's here's the general of
prescription you've got sort of two
pieces to it the first is find some non
complicated state with a some sort of
reasonable angle with the ground state
so if we pretend this is the ground
state okay justice I've got it here
here's the ground state first find
something that's pretty not complex okay
that has some non-trivial hang over the
ground state and now if you have an a
GSP as well you can apply it and what
does it do and if you apply it a bunch
of times it's going to rapidly move what
you have close to the ground state and
since the original guy that you started
with wasn't too complex right and there
you've got some calibration on the
complexity of the a GSP right by the
time you're done because it's a rapidly
moving process you you can bound the
complexity and it turns out so so we can
sort of see very clearly the role of the
agency and the second thing it turns out
that that to get the difficult thing is
this the difficult thing is finding or
showing that there exists a relatively
non complex state that has any
non-trivial inner product of the ground
state not you know serve a random one
will have exponentially small but you
want to get anything up to sort of one
over poly small that's theirs that's the
hard part of the problem and
let's see so now i have to do triage in
one minute descriptive i'm just going to
give you a sense of the more precise
sense of what the AGS these are in terms
of the parameters so remember an
approximate ground state projection has
have two parameters associated to it one
is how well does it shrink things
towards the ground state how fast it
does that and that's depicted here as a
sort of picture where the eigen value
associated to the ground state is one
and all the eigen value is associated to
everything else are below some parameter
delta which so it means that shrinks it
cuts it by delta x so we call that the
sort of shrinking parameter and the
second is a level of complexity which i
wish i had time to talk about but it's
just it's the simplest that you can
imagine it's it's the amount of a linear
combination of amount of simple tensor
products that you need to describe the
the operator so if a simple thing would
just be the product of a term on the
left side acting on the left and a term
acting on the right and now we can sort
of ask for linear combinations of those
and ask for the number of the number of
terms in that linear combination to be
small enough that's the complexity we're
talking about as deep and it turns out
that when you can if you can construct
such a thing for which d times Delta is
less than 1 then you get an areola so
the hope the whole name of the game is
to do this and that's true in any
dimensions if you can get this to work
out and the way Diaz units whatever
energy what's that Diaz units whatever
energy d has no DRDs an integer all
right as much as it can be as big as so
d is the number of terms it's just the
number of karma snake
this may track well for up for the
operator so it's a little bit Delta
Delta Delta has yeah so we've normalized
the Hamiltonian the individual terms the
Hamiltonians tab norm one and the deltas
okay and so uh let's see can I go a few
minutes over what do you what do you
think what how do I five minutes same
time we should do for getting yeah okay
so there's nothing worse than the talk
that goes over when you're expecting it
not to so I apologize for it but anyway
let me just tell you how this idea d
delta being less than a half would sort
of get you what is what is the hard part
it's getting a state with a non-trivial
overlap with the ground state and the
idea is very simple and intuitive so i
want to give it to you because it's sort
of something you can take away and the
idea is the following start with an
under to an entangled state sort of
something that's very simple and it has
some inner product probably much too
small than what you want right it's sort
of almost or thought but now buddy hit
it with the a GSP and what does that do
that moves it closer but what is it due
to it also makes it more complex right
so how much closer does it move it move
it it sort of increases its inner
product by a factor of 1 over delta but
now it's it's it's it's describable it's
it's sort of instead of being one term
it's now d terms that's what the that's
what acting a bike a have done is made
the new state is some of these simple
terms well okay it's d simple terms so
at least one of those terms should have
inner product that has increased by not
a factor of 1 over delta but 1 over d
times that right so at least pick out
the one term for whose inner product is
now increased by the factor 1 over delta
x 1 over d because they're only d terms
okay so what you end up with right is
you pick out the one with the best
overlap but because d delta is a half
you
increase the overlap by your now back to
where you were before a simple state
right but now you're overlap is doubled
so you just kind of keep doing this
until you know this was really an
approximation for what's going on and it
turns out that once you're close enough
this approximation starts did not be
it's not not be as good but while you're
while you'r strictly orthogonal the
factor really is a factor of 1 over
delta so you can just sort of argue that
hey I could have kept doing this and so
in the end I would have ended up with
the state and what i end up with the
state is that some state that has
overlap about 1 over whatever d and from
there you're you've got the first step
until now you apply any a dsb to kind of
the rest so many fun step of this then
again you get into a non entangled
states right yeah so you are always
stepping on an entangled state yeah
however states however you know that the
solution is an antagonistic yeah but
this I guess that's why you get stuck
somewhere yeah and remember we're trying
to do step one of this we're trying to
end up with a very simple state that has
a reasonable inner product but not
necessarily that close and then at you
know that argument works for a while and
so we can get something someone at which
point it stops working because we're
close enough so that that approximation
that you're actually increasing by 1
over Delta isn't quite right
both states don't work anymore then you
hit it then you start to increase the
complexity but now because you're close
enough it's a rapid convergence to the
ground state so you don't have to do it
for very long so you've started with an
untangle thing then you do you hit it
and it's in fact that's you know well
okay that's probably where I should stop
so let me see if there's anything I was
I realize I didn't get to talk about the
algorithm at all but there's a you can
find that by talking to me separately
and so here here's here's just let me
just do the concluding slide right way
so so this this approximate ground state
projection has these quite dramatic
effects right both on simulation and
structure in 1d and there's reason to
think that this is a new tool and the
constructions that our user kind of a
very interesting in terms of they
weren't so easy to come by and it seems
to be rather subtle and so in terms of
things that I want to would hope for
coming out of this semester definitely
some sort of progress or just sort of
these are the questions that i would
like to think about to the area law for
sure a more local one D algorithm the
algorithm right now sort of has to sort
of take into account everything it sort
of sweeps across the state would be nice
if somehow it could be modular and work
on pieces of state independently I think
that's a sort of an attractive thing and
I have some ideas about that is this
questionably with the gaps that we
haven't really we've really been
specializing to the place where there's
a unique ground state a gap and I think
there are a lot of interesting questions
when the when there's not a unique
grants and surprisingly it doesn't seems
like some more ideas are going to be
needed I having sort of felt like I
understood something once I start
thinking about those things I don't feel
like
understood very much of all sort of kind
of embarrassing Lee I mean silly
questions I don't know the answer to and
then hopefully there's some different
questions of these mandates so thanks
questions about this is safe
yeah so for thermals oh just like low
energy no no like Sir you say about baby
not the ground state but like a few
entries I don't think so so I think the
reasons are that you've got CF so the
reasons are one is sort of this progress
on the 1d and the sort of this idea is
that these approximate ground state
protections and and some of the other
ideas in one day they were sort of
showing up I think the others is because
of the set of people who are accumulated
right now right here which is sort of
this kind of I think they're sort of
some there's some it's my understanding
that physicists have a set of intuitions
that I really do not have and I I think
there's some costs talk that would
really be helpful to have at this point
in terms of yeah I just think it's just
sort of a good time
this is it really crucial to cross sort
of similar to select at your customer um
no no no no it's similar so these are
good questions to ask I don't know the
answer uh right off the top of my head
in it's unclear for the moment I mean
these are really quite recent in terms
of thinking suit it's like they're at
the moment whether they're real barriers
or not but they're definitely good
questions the same sort of question I
mean if you start talking about a
higher-dimensional you know the next
highest energy you know perhaps a
simpler version of that question would
be suppose the two lowest energy so it's
the same right which is sort of gets
through two dimensional ground space and
so now
all right let's think zip again